a bola sobe 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer uma mini pistola que te para
triste lá tcos e os torcedores celestes
que são os ativos e pulseiras com
bastante baratos estão todos lá da venda
e vai voltar mas antes de usar a
proteção porque os elásticos podem estar
por trás até então porque são sempre
vamos ver como ela se comporta é
precisam dela é muito boa
eles podem ver os autos proteção futebol
pra mim pra trás e com embalagem que
traz 50 então sair você consegue fazer
armas para o bairro inteiro andar a
brincar uns contra os outros mas claro
sem poucos proteção aqui a gente para
até 10 metros ou seja da parte paraguaia
então é isso agora vamos usar mais
alguns testes pois o tutorial passo a
passo boa então vamos lá
comecem por marcar o meio de dois
pontinhos de picolé os meus 2011 ou seja
ganham cola num dos lados
e qual é a outro mas atenção as
marcações do maio estão ligeiramente
desviado os juntem as partes centrais
dos dois políticos e depois corta em
cima dessa marcação usar uma serra usada
por custar um tal mas se vocês quiserem
podem usar uma faca ou então uma tesoura
mas fica mais prefeitinho usando é
serrinha foi um dos convênios por baixo
e mark no segundo polito a largura da
impunidade dura e depois faça o mesmo
ali na parte de baixo
assim ali com muito cuidado o que
acontece é que às vezes quebra no
cadastro
talvez com muito cuidado funciona é a
gente pode escutar os produtinhos tem
curricular os vejo que o puzzle um
palito que não está pressionada e no
abuso na cola aqui para não prender o
polito
por que é que ele tem que ficar imóvel é
e vai servir para fazer o vídeo depois
para finalizar a parte em pintura é só
por cola nestas três partidas e colar o
outro pedaço aqui agora vocês têm que
marcar está hoje vejam como é feita a
lei
o traço corta em 1 e tem que fazer outro
igual ou seja é só vocês sobre o por ele
ao poder de picolé marcarem encurtar em
que vai ficar mais ou menos igual sempre
passar pelo lixo é muito importante
fazer isso foi uma pequena gota de cola
aqui com cuidado para não colar aquela
parte móvel a identificá-lo e tudo lá
também
se vocês prender e móvel já não vai
funcionar agora com lixa
vocês têm que andar isto muito bem mesmo
para conseguir pois tirar os elásticos
quando aquilo ali
o tamanho e depois de encurtar mais um
todo assim bem pequenino que vai servir
para fazer um coletivo e sim
agora só falta mesmo fazer e vou fazer
três agora se vocês quiserem fazer uma
pistola para mais vezes podem usar ou um
conflito maior ou então podem puxar que
neste caso o pleito ver mais para trás e
encontrou espaço para pôr mais cinco
seis sete e vejam que eu posso lhe
políticos do brasil e acha que vou fazer
aquela parte inicial e final que é mais
complicado fazer usando facas
e como eu disse no início o site lastex
de pulseiras que servem muito bem
é a que é isso chegamos ao fim
agora é este maluco vai falar vamos
matar lake oi e tchau tchau para
testemunhar